on va parler de cette campagne Frédéric
on va regarder votre sondage
Ifop sur les intentions de vote et c'est
toujours Emmanuel Macron qui est en tête
largement
donc tous les jours nous produisons un
rapport de force et c'est vrai qu'on a
un Emmanuel Macron en pôle position qui
s'est quand même érodé sur la longue
durée il est passé de 27 à 24 et demi
notamment sur la question de la crise
covid et de cette thématique du pouvoir
d'achat derrière lui il y a une
incertitude pour la deuxième place avec
Marine Le Pen et va et Perez qui sont
dans la marche d'erreur 18 et demi
contre 16 et
Eric Zemmour qui après son coup d'arrêt
il y a ses propos sur les enfants en
situation de handicap à retrouver de la
vigueur il a gagné un point et demi en à
peine trois jours le fait majeur sur ces
15 premiers jours d'attention de vote
c'est la situation de la gauche en
perdition à un niveau global jamais
observé autour de 25% un petit avantage
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais qui n'est
pas dans une logique de dynamique et
effectivement les choses sont figées
parce qu'il y a ce que disait Arnaud
benedettiste à cette campagne qui avance
doucement qui est peut-être sur un faux
plat sortie du covid pas sorti du covid
entrer d'Emmanuel Macron dans le jeu
présidentiel en tout cas il y a un
paradoxe assez incroyable si je peux
dire sur ces débuts de campagne
concernant cette primaire de droite
extrême Zemmour Le Pen Marine Le Pen
n'est pas aujourd'hui en situation
automatique d'être au second tour comme
en 2017 à la même époque elle était à 23
24 % elle était sur d'être première ou
finalement deuxième mais son image c'est
clairement rétabli parce que elle a
refilé le le mistigri si je puis dire de
l'extrémisme et du candidat repoussoir à
Éric Zemmour
finalement de l'évolution des intentions
de vente depuis maintenant une quinzaine
de jours voir d'ailleurs presque trois
semaines c'est quand même la bonne
résistance de Marine Le Pen dans un
contexte politique qui est très
compliqué pour elle avec une très forte
pression quand même du zemourisme sur
une partie de son électorat et parfois
une partie de ces cartes et de ce point
de vue là quand on regarde toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion on voit que Marine Le
Pen même si elle n'est pas sûr d'accéder
au second tour et quand même en position
de pouvoir toujours accéder au second
tour avec finalement une capacité à
résister d'un côté à la dynamique
Zemmour qui a commencé à s'implanter
dans le paysage maintenant à partir de
l'automne mais également à la dynamique
Pécresse on se souvient de ce rebond
quasi technique que le Congrès des
républicains avait provoqué sur la
candidature à l'époque de Valérie
Pécresse qui était même donné un moment
donné comme potentiel vainqueur dans un
second tour face au président Macron ce
qui en tout cas aujourd'hui donc cette
bande capacité de résistance fait que
finalement le phénomène peut-être
important c'est justement le fait que le
vote du rassemblement national reste
encore assez solide contenu en effet du
contexte du contexte politique ensuite
bon la gauche Frédéric Davian on a parlé
le problème de la gauche c'est que on ne
voit pas aujourd'hui
à brève échéance une issue qui
permettrait à la gauche d'avoir un
candidat en mesure de créer une
dynamique en sa faveur et de rassembler
bien évidemment les forces de gauche on
va parler de la primaire populaire dans
quelques instants mais d'abord sur ce
duel Éric Zemmour Marine Le Pen est-ce
que comme le diarno Marine Le Pen elle a
une base stable et elle a résisté à
l'entrée en campagne d'Éric Zemmour et à
la résisté au rebond de Valérie Pécresse
ou est-ce que il y a un vote caché
Zemmour comme il y avait un vote caché
Le Pen en 2002 alors c'est résiste bien
c'est vrai qu'Eric Zemmour assez score
les plus élevés dans des segments qui
sont susceptibles de voter pour
rassemblement national les catégories
générationnelles intermédiaires les 25
34 ans les 50 64 ans c'est catégories
charnières qui sont plus en souffrance
que les autres qui peuvent être tentés
par un vote pour tester le chiffre que
je regarde chaque jour dans notre ligne
il faut fiduciale c'est la part des
lecteurs l'Open 2017 qui choisirait Éric
Zemmour il y en a environ chaque jour
25% ça fait un score important quand on
est même temps on a 20% à 25% des
électeurs Fillon qui choisiraient
regzemmour et ça ça bouge pas c'est
alors ça peut fluctuer ça expliquer les
baisses d'Éric Zemmour et les remontées
c'est vraiment c'est le seul candidat
qui acheterait deux sources électorales
présidentielles très forte alors
maintenant la question du vote caché si
je puis dire on connaîtra la vérité à la
fin du film aujourd'hui on est incapable
de vous dire si c'est vrai si c'est faux
je pense que c'est un argument qui a été
imposé par les amis et des proches
d'Éric Zemmour et je vois que les médias
en braille dans le sens où ils font
créer un débat là-dessus il y a déjà une
j'apporterai une réserve technique sur
le fait que il y a un vote caché on
n'ose pas dire qu'on va voter eczemmour
parce qu'il est c'est le candidat du
coup d'éclat permanent un candidat qui
est très cash en 2012 c'était vrai en
2002 c'était complètement vrai je donne
toujours cette anecdote quelques jours
après le 21 avril j'étais à l'époque
institut CSA nous réalisons une enquête
de ceux de ceux de second tour et le
vote Le Pen 2 jours après le 21 avril
sort en brut à 6 à 7%. pourquoi c'était
du téléphone donc il y avait une
difficulté à avouer à un enquêteur qu'on
allait voter qu'on avait voté deux jours
avant pour Jean-Marie Le Pen là toutes
les enquêtes en janvier juste en janvier
2002 Jean-Marie Le Pen c'était 8% dans
cette chambre
au poteau là les enquêtes
présidentielles depuis trois
présidentielles depuis 2012 sont faites
en ligne donc
les lecteurs l'individu et face à son
smartphone face à son ordinateur face à
sa tablette alors je ne vois pas
la situation d'un électeur Zemmour qui
va se cacher à lui-même le fait de voter
pour moi il peut y avoir une
sous-décration il peut y avoir une sur
déclaration le vote le pas de maintenant
et parfois quand je regarde les les
votes antérieures 2017 les
reconstitutions de vote et parfois sur
déclaré j'habite noter les spectateurs
aller sur le site de la Commission des
sondages ils verront chaque jour la part
des votes antérieures est-ce qu'ils sont
déclarés sous déclarés etc donc moi je
ne crois pas à ce vote caché et
l'argument que l'on avance excusez-moi
je suis un petit peu long l'argument qui
est en fait avancé pour dire ah il n'a
jamais été testé par le passé les
sondeurs ont du mal à le redresser c'est
à dire retrouver son rapport de force ça
ne tient pas Emmanuel Macron en 2017
n'avait pas je dirais et encore moins
que Éric Zemmour la moindre existence
électorale et les enquêtes de 2007 ont
plutôt bien évalué moi ce qui me fait
peur ce que je crains pour le travail
des sondeurs dans la perspective du 10
avril six mois sur votre cachet que la
volatilité extraordinaire entre les
candidats imaginez on peut en trouver là
en revanche beaucoup des électeurs de
gauche qui vont être sur un vote idéal
le lundi le mardi et en dernier recours
qui voterait par exemple Taubira donc
voilà je donne des exemples complètement
fictifs mais et pareil cette volatilité
Zemmour Pécresse Zemmour Le Pen ça peut
avoir des forts mouvements en fin de
campagne qui seront très difficiles à
mesurer alors on a bien compris que
techniquement le vote caché ne peut pas
être le même en 2002 qu'en 2022 mais
est-ce que politiquement Éric Zemmour il
peut gagner des parts de marché sur
Marine Le Pen puisque vous l'avez dit
Arnaud il est plus radical il répond
peut-être plus à l'électorat d'extrême
droite et elle du coup et elle devient
un peu plus centriste entre guillemets
pour l'électorat d'extrême droite de
marché l'avenir nous le dira la réalité
c'est que moi j'ai le sentiment mais
peut-être que je me trompe c'est que
finalement
ceux qui parmi les soutiens de Marine Le
Pen ou même parmi les républicains qui
souhaitent une offre politique plus
radicale sont déjà passées dans ce camp
là c'est à dire qu'en fait ils ont déjà
opéré ce transfert et que aujourd'hui
quoi qu'il arrive il vautrons pour Éric
Zemmour quoi que si je regarde la
certitude du choix et ça c'est important
il me semble que c'est dans le sondage
libre on voit que celle qui a la plus
forte certitude de choix c'est Marine Le
Pen en l'occurrence bien loin
devant les autres l'ensemble des autres
candidats et bien loin devant surtout
Éric Zemmour donc ça c'est quand même un
facteur qu'il faut prendre en compte et
qui montre que d'une certaine manière
elle a réussi à sa façon à fidéliser une
partie de ces parts de marché donc ça
c'est le premier point ensuite moi si
vous voulez ce qui ne milite pas en
faveur d'un vote caché dont on voit que
c'est un argument Frédéric la
parfaitement dit de campagne de la part
de l'entourage d'Éric Zemmour c'est que
si vous voulez on n'est plus en 2002
au-delà des questions des conditions de
faisabilité des sondages qui ont
évidemment ont changé par rapport à 2002
c'est qu'on est plus en 2002 c'est que
en 2002 on était dans un contexte une
atmosphère ou finalement on était
beaucoup moins transgressif qu'on ne
l'est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a plus
de facilité d'une certaine manière parce
que c'est peut-être les réseaux sociaux
qui ont des inhibé un certain nombre
d'expressions à dire ce que l'on va
faire et moi ce que je note quand même
c'est que je crois que il est beaucoup
plus facile de dire pour un certain
nombre d'électrices et d'électeurs de
droites que l'on va voter pour exemmour
qui n'était facile de le dire qu'on
allait voter pour Jean-Marie Le Pen
c'est-à-dire qu'en fin de compte le
paradoxe de la candidature d'Éric
Zemmour c'est que c'est une candidature
qui est parfois beaucoup plus
radicalisée que celle de Marine Le Pen
qui comme vous l'avez justement dit
c'est profondément recentré mais que
cette radicalisation cette forme de de
j'allais dire de dépassement sur sa
droite de Marine Le Pen ne nuit pas
forcément à à à l'image d'Eric zoemmour
et ne le surdiabolise pas et ça c'est je
pense un élément important qu'il faut
prendre en compte et qui limite à mon
avis l'argument du vote caché Frédéric
apprend à parler de la primaire
populaire oui
sur un autre plan que le plan technique
par Arnaud Benedetti c'est vrai que Éric
Zemmour on peut écrire deux scénarios de
scénaristes c'est-à-dire il continue à
prendre un double électorat le penfillon
et là il va connaître une il peut
connaître une véritable dynamique même
si c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
le vote radical de droite extrême a
quand même trouvé son candidat on a vu
une fort dynamique à automne dernier ou
bien ou bien dans une logique de vote
utile si vous êtes toujours sur une un
match pour la place qualificative pour
le second tour entre Marine Le Pen et
Valérie Pécresse des antipécresse on se
dit malgré tout cette Marine Le Pen elle
pourra peut-être battait elle pourra
peut-être battre Emmanuel Macron mais
elle est quand même le mieux placée pour
éviter
un duel le Macron Pécresse ou bien le
cas inverse pour être si je puis dire
avancer et donc dans ce cadre là une
logique de vote pourrait faire
s'effondrer Éric Zemmour quel sera vers
quelle solution ira le scénario de la
campagne personne ne peut dire en tout
cas ce qui frappe c'est la solidité
d'Éric Zemmour sur sa capacité à capter
un électorat de droite et de droite
extrême
[Musique]